hey folks if you'd like to support me or
this channel move university in creating
more video tutorials then please
consider making a financial contribution
at my website booth university comm
thanks and enjoy the video so in the
last video we talked about
glycerophospholipids and those
glycerophospholipids that we talked
about had ester linkages but there are
some that have ether linkage as a equal
linkages as opposed to these ester
linkages so the ester linkage I'm
talking about is right here for instance
between the second carbon of the
glycerol backbone and this acyl group is
fatty acyl group that's the ester
linkage there but what if there is an
ether linkage ethers as you may or may
not know look like this they're
basically the the carbon analogues of
water right water looks like this
alright it's bent structure looks like
that so if you replace those hydrogen's
with carbon chains you have what's
called an ether an ether functional
group so that's what's going on up here
we have an ether linkage we have the
carbon of the glycerol backbone and the
carbon of some R group okay and of
course the rest remains the same we saw
the phosphate group and some alcohol but
this is a glycerophospholipid with an
ether linkage instead of an ester
linkage now there are two examples I
want to talk about there are these
things called plasma legions and there's
the specific visceral phospholipid
within with an e so think it's called
they lacked a activating factor that
I'll get to in a moment so plasma
legions look like this they're
characterized by having a carbon-carbon
double bond between carbon a and carbon
B which are basically the first two
carbons on the ether R group so if we
think about the the the R group up here
from the ether these first two carbons
carbon a and carbon B are the first two
carbons of that R group so if it's a
double bond there that's one of the
characteristics of a plasma Lajja that's
one thing the other thing is that there
is a
an ester linkage on carbon two so if we
have a double bond between the first two
carbons of the R group on a peer from
the ether linkage and an ester linkage
on the second the second group then we
have what's called a plasma legend now
plasma legends actually play a role in
fighting against reactive oxygen species
which can go through an oxidizing damage
biological molecules so pathogens play a
role in fighting fighting off against
those and they're also important in
signaling as signaling molecules but
that sort of idea is not really well
understood so I really don't know too
much about that but I mainly meant would
brought this up because an example of a
glycerophospholipid with an ether
linkage and it has a specific definition
right having that double bond there and
having this ester bond here now there is
this thing there's molecule called
platelet activating factor which has an
R group that has 16 carbons here so
that's a 16 carbon chain in the 16
carbon chain in the ether linkage and
then there specifically an acetyl ester
here right this is an acetyl group here
it's an acetyl ester linkage and over
here this the alcohol is attached is
actually choline this specific list for
a phospholipid with this ether linkage
right I just point out the ether linkage
specifically in both these cases that
ether linkage that ether linkage this
specific list or phospholipid with the
same ether linkage is called platelet
activating factor and this molecule is
actually fairly well understood it
stimulates platelet aggregation which
basically is and platelets are involved
in clotting blood clotting and this
thing is involved in the inflammatory
response
response and the allergic response so
this molecule is important in when it
comes to inflammation and when it comes
to allergies so this thing is actually a
glycerophospholipid with an ether
leakage that's actually fairly waters
that I really just wanted to bring this
up as examples because of this
distinction with of these ether linkages
so hope that was at least somewhat
interesting thank you for watching
yo if you found that video helpful don't
forget a like comment subscribe for more
content and if you know anybody who
might find the video is helpful then
please share with them Thanks happy
studying